momento de hablar de economía aquí en
directo américa en francés 24 está con
nosotros en el estudio daniel hablando
para comenzar hablando de temas
relacionados de américa latina' hablamos
de venezuela la moneda se deprecia para
la economía habíamos informado ha ido
mejorando poco a poco qué es lo que pasa
allí sin santiago pues mire la
cotización oficial del dólar cerró este
jueves en 786 bolívares con un alza de
más del 10 por ciento y en lo que va de
la semana al bolívar se ha depreciado en
cerca de una cuarta parte este
comportamiento como usted lo dice se da
justo días después de que el banco
central anunciara que el país había
reportado un crecimiento económico sin
precedentes del 17 04 por ciento
interanual esto en el primer trimestre
de 2022 el presidente nicolás maduro ha
venido implementando el uso del dólar
para controlar la inflación que en julio
llegó a 137 por ciento interanual según
el banco central aunque el país
sudamericano ya salió de la
hiperinflación sigue sumergido en una
recesión que inició en 2014
o sea es una situación bien difícil si
todo lo incrementan todo estaba por las
nubes entonces que pienso que tiene que
haber un aumento de sueldo 1 una
regulación de la economía ya tenemos una
inflación muy alta en venezuela
pudiéramos tener una inflación aún más
alta por esta dinámica que ya conocemos
de que cuando el tipo de cambio salta se
escapa
inmediatamente los precios comienzan
también a ajustarse al alza de venezuela
hablamos ahora de perú daniela porque el
gobierno cree que el crecimiento
económico que está presentando el país
no va a ser suficiente para alcanzar las
metas que eran muchas claro vale la pena
iniciar contándoles que hoy el ejecutivo
ajustó a la baja su proyección de
crecimiento del país en abril había
pronosticado un alza promedio anual del
pib del 3 6% entre 2024 y 2026 ahora
cree que será tres décimas menor es
decir del 33 por ciento el ministro de
economía explicó que por ejemplo el
ritmo actual de crecimiento será
insuficiente para cumplir objetivos como
por ejemplo el ingreso a la organización
para la cooperación y el desarrollo
económico ocde escuchemos lo que dijo el
ministro
inferiores es lo que necesitamos y es
por eso creo que es sumamente útil
plantear un conjunto de medidas que
puedan acelerar el crecimiento económico
porque como les digo si no hacemos nada
no estamos aspirando tasas de
crecimiento bastante pequeñas que
impactan vamos a decirlo así y no
resolución no inicio resolución
como por ejemplo lo que es en su empleo
el empleo informal si usted es ciudadano
francés es maestro y está en américa
latina' atención porque en francia están
buscando soluciones precisamente a las
casas de maestros así de santiago que
parezca increíble mire funcionarios del
país galo han debatido esta semana sobre
cómo atraer a más maestros pues según el
ministerio de educación más de 4.000
puestos de docentes siguen vacantes de
cara al inicio de la temporada escolar
el presidente de manuel macro en ha
dicho que continuará con el aumento
salarial de maestros que comenzó en 2020
y también dijo que ningún docente
comenzará a trabajar con menos de dos
mil euros al mes lo que supondría una
subida de cerca del 10 por ciento de
respecto al sueldo actual este panorama
ha llevado a que los colegios hagan
entrevistas de trabajo rápidas para
contratar a la mayor cantidad de
profesores antes de esta crisis el
gobierno pedía por ejemplo que los
maestros estatales tuvieran maestría en
educación y también que aprobaran un
difícil examen de certificación pero
ahora están reduciendo considerablemente
estas exigencias clases de periodismo
por ejemplo iniciativa twitter gana una
pequeña batalla contra hilo en moscú en
el tribunal del estado de delaware que
fue lo que pasó bueno sigue esta pelea
entonces el considerado hombre más rico
del mundo y la red social recordemos
irán a un juicio de cinco días en
delaware el próximo 17 de octubre
relacionado con el fallido acuerdo de
compra el dueño de tesla ha pedido
acceso a todos los datos de los casi 200
millones de usuarios de la red social
pero la respuesta de la juez catalina
mccormick fue que sus solicitudes ya son
absurdamente amplias y que requerirán
que el demandante en este caso twitter
produzca trillones y trillones de puntos
de datos lo que sí hizo la magistrada en
una pequeña victoria para el
multimillonario fue ordenarle a twitter
entregar información de las nueve mil
cuentas muestreadas en el cuarto
trimestre de 2021 ya que recordemos
santiago ésta ha sido el principal
argumento de mosca para querer desistir
de este negocio multimillonario y
cerramos la sección de economía con la
cifra del día daniel bueno para los
amantes de las consolas 14 mil 999 pesos
mexicanos que costará ahora un play 5 en
méxico esto equivale a unos 750 dólares
y porque le traigo esta cifra colación
santiago porque son y anunció que debido
al desafiante entorno económico mundial
se vio obligada a elevar el precio
minorista para la versión más reciente
de su consola en europa medio oriente
asia pacífico y américa latina solamente
eeuu es alta yo seguiré cuando tetris en
mi teléfono entonces así muchas gracias
daniela es todo por el momento aquí en
directo américa en economía en noticias
a continuación el debate
[Música]